[Applaudissements]
vous nous raconterez le père qui
dessinait des filles à poil qui vous
amenaient à la Fête de l'Humanité en
Jaguar enfin voilà nous rencontrer tout
ça ça s'appelle j'ai pas épousé mon père
et c'est publié chez Michel Lafont
le résultat du jeu de la pub cherchez
l'intrus quel l'intrus entre Richard
Anconina Claude Berry Dominique Farrugia
Doc Gynéco Stomy Bugsy Frédéric
Diefenthal ou Christophe Lambert stomie
pourquoi c'est le seul qui a des
moustaches ouais ce serait non mais ça
pourrait voilà c'est ça
qui n'a pas vécu avec Elsa
le plus attentionné c'était lequel
Frédéric diphène
le plus aimé sur le moment c'est pas
pareil j'ai beaucoup aimé Dominique
Farrugia mais je les ai tous beaucoup
aimé quand même messieurs toutes ces
informations sont dans le livre d'Elsa
Wolinski qui s'appelle j'ai pas épousé
mon père en le pitch c'est quand on est
fils de ouf fils de on croit avoir
automatiquement arrêté des gènes du
succès au lieu de ça dites-vous j'ai
merdouillé pendant 15 ans quand on est
élevé dans la gauche caviar qu'on a la
chance de tout avoir on moi je pensais
que j'allais à 15 ans avoir déjà eu mon
premier César à 17 écrit mon premier
livre et que je me retrouve à trois ans
avoir fait un livre c'est déjà pas mal
un enfant et un enfant une petite fille
de 15 mois alors justement quand vous
étiez enfant vous aimez bien aller aux
enterrements parce que vous disiez c'est
là qu'on voit le plus de people comme
j'étais toujours emmené par mon père
chez Castel j'ai très jeune c'est vrai
que j'avais ce goût là depuis Paul
j'avais ce goût des paillettes et c'est
vrai que les enterrements dont celui de
rejeter rond d'ailleurs qui est l'ancien
patron de Paris Match il y avait
énormément de monde donc ça m'a un peu
mais comme vous étiez petit vous rêviez
d'être connu de tricher ses lèvres
j'étais aussi amoureuse de vous
[Applaudissements]
normalement non non non non
c'est vrai vous dites que quand vous
arrivez dans une soirée vous n'êtes pas
au bras de votre père ou d'un riche et
célèbre amant ça vous gêne qu'on vous
qu'on vous reconnaisse pas tout de suite
quoi pendant des années quand on a été
habitué à sortir avec son père partout
chez Castel ou ailleurs
j'étais connu comme ça et puis après
quand on a des amandes plutôt célèbres
aussi et après on se rend compte que
quand on est seul on est un peu rien
vous dites que vous avez appris à jouer
en regardant des films porno quand même
j'ai piqué en fait en douce les
cassettes porno de mon papa et comme il
recevait que des films de tracylorde ou
sûrement peut-être qu'il était fan de
Tristan donc effectivement voilà j'ai
appris comme ça
c'est votre mari en fait qui vous le dit
à un moment ça enfin il me dit surtout
arrête de jouer surtout que je baise mal
en fait
mais non mais il a un peu raison parce
que c'est vrai que je jouais un peu la
comédie puisque j'étais j'avais appris
en regardant je suis enjoué
et est-ce qu'il y a des photos
[Applaudissements]
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu